when you have a monopoly over anything
you believe that your monopoly will last
forever everyone always has the roman
empire did the third reich social media
companies when you have a monopoly we're
smarter than all the other control
mechanisms in multis we're never going
anywhere we're too smart and the funny
thing about monopolies and tyranny is
that you have to use force
and force is something i understand very
very well force is a very very powerful
tool until it's overused let's use the
romanian example just because i live in
romania the only reason i'm going to use
it
there's a riot there's a protest you
send the army
get rid of it riot protests send the
army get rid of it riot protests send
the army trying to get rid of it they
won't leave open fire on protesters
too much people have had enough
then you end up ousted
there comes a point where you can use
force but once it's overused and people
don't believe in your fairness people
don't believe in the fact that you're
non-biased and you're still using force
there is a mass uprising